at seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
a viable alternative to quarantine the
government-backed study trials daily
tests
as a substitute for self-isolation for
those who've come into contact with a
positive covid case
i want to be carefree sky news speaks to
the sickle cell warrior determined to
raise awareness of the disease
sometimes i can be looking forward to
something like having a sleepover or
going to watch a movie
and then all of that can change with the
second and i can
end up in hospital
preparing for the polls sky sophie ridge
takes a look at which way wales may vote
come elections later this week
and portrait of a princess a new
photograph is released by kensington
palace to celebrate princess charlotte's
sixth birthday
in the sport manchester city could seal
the premier league title today if rivals
manchester united
moves to liverpool
and it's a sunny and showery sunday and
a wet and windy bank holiday monday
typical
conditions for a bank holiday weekend
i'll have details for you later in the
program
and at quarter two we'll take a look at
the newspapers with the journalists and
feminist campaigner julie bindle
and the writer and political commentator
esther kraken
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
people who come into close contact with
someone with covid may not need to
self-isolate any more
if a new trial proves to be successful
daily lateral flow
tests will be given to as many as 40 000
people who have a positive coronavirus
contact
in the government-backed research so
long as they stay negative or weak
they can carry on with their lives
without having to isolate
well emma birchley joins me now from the
the newsroom and emma uh
when does this all start and how exactly
is it going to be implemented
so it all starts next sunday and if it
turns out that you have been in close
contact with someone who's tested
positive for coronavirus then
you could well get a call and be offered
the chance to take part in the study
you'll then be sent seven lateral flow
tests you have one each morning and as
long as the result
is negative and you're not displaying
any symptoms
then you can carry on with life as
normal and we know that those results
come through
in about 30 minutes so it's all about
trying to get back to some kind of
normality people not needing to
self-isolate at home for 10 days which
causes so much disruption has such an
impact on working lives social lives
and also of course the knock-on of that
on the economy now
pilots have already been carried out in
hospitals businesses
some schools and this will build on that
there is of course some concern about
the accuracy of these lateral flow tests
but actually
there's one in a thousand false
positives and
to make sure that people uh get the
accurate result they will then go on if
they've had a positive to have a pcr
test which is seen as being more
accurate just to make sure that the
results
are right um this is a
a study that's being led by public
health england
and by nh nhs test and trace and it's
being backed
by the government uh everyone hoping
that it will work to try and reduce the
need for people to
self-isolate at home and as i said it
will begin
next sunday emma thank you
and we'll be joined by the lead author
of that study professor isabel oliver in
about 10 minutes time so do stay with us
for that
let's have a look at the latest
coronavirus figures now for the uk
they've been 1907 new cases of
coronavirus while
seven more deaths have been reported it
means the total number of people who
died
due to the virus is 127
524 meanwhile another 129
657 people have received their first
vaccination
and 405 456 people got their second
that means more than 34.3 million jabs
have now been given out
across the uk
an 11 year old girl who has sickle cell
anemia says
more support is needed for people living
with the disease
mia phillip is calling for greater
awareness of the hereditary illness
following the death of 19 year old
student richard okorage
who went missing after spending a year
shielding because of his condition
while an inquest earlier this month
found that another sickle cell sufferer
evan nathan smith
who rang at 999 from his hospital bed
after being refused oxygen
wouldn't have died if medical staff had
recognized his symptoms
and offered him a blood transfusion
sooner shingi mararike reports
so what we think so i really like this i
think it goes good in the life
on the surface maya is like any other 11
year old girl
with hopes dreams and aspirations
a natural-born performer she is already
well on her way to becoming an actress
away from performing however real life
can be tough
every single day she deals with sickle
cell
the hereditary disease is caused by
abnormally shaped red blood cells
creating blockages in the bloodstream
these result in extreme epitomes of pain
known as crises
they can last hours days or months
the condition can even be fatal if i get
too excited about something that can
also trigger a crisis
so i always have to be level like okay
i'm really excited but i have to stay
calm
but yeah sometimes i can be looking
forward to something like having a
sleepover or going to watch a movie
and then all of that can change with the
second and then i can end up in hospital
on a blood transfusion or it's it's
frustrating because sometimes you feel
like you just want to be able to live
to be carefree she did ask
why do i have sickle cell she said by
this why did god
give me sickle cell and
if i'm being honest i wasn't ready for
that question this is where i keep
all my medicines around 15 000 people in
britain suffer from sickle cell
the majority are from african caribbean
backgrounds
it has been thrust into the limelight by
a recent tragedy
oh looky oh my god you're glowing the
death of richard okaragaye
a 19 year old student founded last month
after he had spent a year shielding with
the illness
before going missing i don't have any
connections with either of the parents
but i cried i felt i felt their pain
this might probably not that it might
happen to me
this mother and daughter have become
activists
fighting to raise awareness this is my
water chart
for them a wider understanding of sickle
cell needs to begin with the medical
profession
to know about diabetes or to even know
about cystic fibrosis
it should be as standard as that it
shouldn't be oh i haven't heard of this
before or
oh i don't know what that is you have
been
in this profession so know about this
profession
know about every single thing in this
profession that you can
for maya who calls herself a sickle cell
warrior
the message to others is a simple one i
know
it's hard sometimes but just continue
doing what you do and make sure you look
after yourself as well especially
yeah now definitely shingi mararike
sky news
let's take a look now at some of the
other stories making the news for you
this morning and
north korea has dismissed the idea of
talks with washington
calling u.s diplomacy efforts spurious
and a way to cover up
its hostile acts in joe biden's first
policy speech as president to congress
on wednesday
he reaffirmed his commitment to
denuclearization but in a series of
statements the north korean foreign
ministry said the speech was intolerable
and a big blunder
israel is holding a national day of
mourning after a deadly stampede killed
45
ultra-orthodox jews at friday's lag
bomber festival
near mount meron the bodies of 32 of the
worshippers have been identified but the
process was suspended to allow for
sabbath the jewish day of rest
prime minister benjamin netanyahu has
promised an investigation into the cause
of the stampede
four children have been hospitalized
after eating sweets thought to contain
cannabis two twelve-year-olds and a
thirteen-year-old were found on pound
lane in epsom after suffering a violent
reaction to the sweets
anybody who has found what appear to be
similar sweets has urged not to destroy
them
and to contact surrey police
caitlyn jenner has said that transgender
athletes who were born
male should not be allowed to compete in
girls
sports teams during what appeared to be
an impromptu interview she told american
website tmz
it was a question of fairness the former
olympic decathlon medalist and reality
tv star came out as transgender
in 2015. jenna recently announced
she would run for california governor as
a republican
the prospect of wales becoming an
independent country used to be very much
a side issue in welsh elections with
health education and the economy
dominating the doorstep debate these
days the idea of breaking away from the
union is a key topic of the campaign
ahead of polls opening on thursday
sophie ridge has been to wales to see
what voters
really care about the last time people
in wales voted for their devolved
parliament
david cameron was prime minister brexit
hadn't happened
and covered 19 didn't even exist
since 2016 it's fair to say a lot has
changed
but will that be reflected in next
thursday's elections
first minister mark drakeford is keen to
capitalize on his record dealing with
the pandemic
but some say that labour's approach in
this campaign has been too modest
well i think we belong in the middle
because that is where the great bulk
of opinion rests in wales it is only the
labour party
that believes in a strong wales in a
successful united kingdom
in the last four years the conservatives
have gained ground in wales
in the 2019 general election they won
six welsh seats off labour
now labour needs to win back some of
those votes just to maintain their
current standing in the welsh parliament
to match our 2016 election result
particularly in the current
circumstances i think would be a very
high water mark for us
because of the gains they made in 2019
the conservatives
should be improving on their 2016 result
anything less would be a failure
we're fighting every constituency in
every regional ballot
we're getting a very good response
indeed it's all about building on 2019 i
accept that and that's why
our strong economic road map out to the
covid crisis is an important part of our
platform
but this election is a three-horse race
club camry may hold the balance of power
hoping to capitalise on a small growth
in support for welsh independence
support is uh increasing indeed
according to some important polls now
even a majority of labour voters
support independence and support for
independence in wales now is
higher than it was in scotland ten years
ago and of course
only a few years later they came within
five percent of winning an independence
referendum and politics is all about
momentum and the momentum
is with the independence movement
plaguery and labour have worked together
in the past
could another coalition be on the cards
we're not prepared to concede
any other possibility than then surging
support
not just for the independence movement
but for player country plyd clearly
don't want to talk about possible
coalitions
just yet but they might have to soon
this is an election full of uncertainty
with seven ukip seats up for grabs
and 16 and 17 year olds voting for the
first time in wales
and if the result is inconclusive which
it may well be
that uncertainty could continue for some
time after as well
sophie ridge sky news
and a reminder that dominic raab will be
live on sophie ridge on
sunday she'll also be joined by shadow
foreign secretary lisa nandy that's at 8
30 this morning
let's take a look now at some of the
other stories making the news for you
this morning and police are searching
for a newborn baby girl
after her parents failed to cooperate
with doctors
who said she needed urgent medical help
azar and michelle graham from south
london
haven't been seen since a postnatal
assessment with their daughter on
thursday
detectives say the seven day old who's
been identified as baby graham needs
urgent treatment
for what could be a serious respiratory
condition
the uk economy is ready for liftoff as
the country emerges from the latest
lockdown
according to the confederation of
british industry it's predicting
economic growth will be felt differently
across sectors though most industries
will grow strongly in the next
three months oscar winning actress
olympia dukakis best known for her role
in the 1987 romantic comedy moonstruck
has died aged 89. her brother apollo
dukakis announced the news on facebook
saying beloved sister olympia dukakis
passed away
this morning in new york city
a spacex capsule carrying four
astronauts has departed the
international space station ending their
five-month mission
the astronauts set a record for the
longest time in space by a crew that
launched aboard an american-built
spacecraft crew members are also aiming
for a rare
nighttime splashdown
a new photograph of princess charlotte
has been released to mark her sixth
birthday today
kensington palace said the image was
captured this weekend in norfolk by her
mother
the duchess of cambridge
let's get more on our top story now and
self-isolating could soon be a thing of
the past if a new trial of daily lateral
flow tests
for those who've come into contact with
someone with covid proves
successful the research is being led by
public health england and i'm joined now
by professor isabelle oliver
who is heading up the study good morning
to you
um just how long will the the trials go
on for and what exactly
will they entail thank you very much and
good morning
the trial will go on until we are able
to recruit sufficient people to the
study
to help us evaluate
the daily contact testing as a safe
alternative to self-isolation
the the study um entails on
uh what we will do as part of the study
is
um i offer contacts of cases of covet 19
the opportunity to participate and as
part of that we will
randomly allocate them to two groups
one group which will be the standard
normal approach
including the requirement to
self-isolate for 10 days
and then the second group will be
offered the opportunity
of taking a a daily
test and if that test is negative
they will be released from the
requirement to isolate for the following
24 hours
when they will be required to take
another test
and they'll do that for um for seven
days
uh and what what is the the aim or the
potential aim is it to
um reduce the the days that that people
have to self-isolate or is it to
eradicate self-isolation altogether
well we know that contacts of cases are
at higher risk of carrying the infection
so one of the key aims is to make sure
that we identify
people who are carrying the infection
among contacts of cases
and that we do that quickly the second
aim
is that we do know that people
particularly some people find
self-isolation very challenging for
example
people who are not able to work from
home
or people who have um a lack of
access to to to support for example
um so this the aim would be to release
people who are
not carrying the infection from the need
to isolate
of course all people testing positive
will still be required to isolate as
normal
and are you happy with the reliability
of the the lateral
flow test because there has been some
criticism that it's not
as precise as the the pcr test
that's right so so we know that these
tests are
um accurate and sufficiently test
sensitive to be used among asymptomatic
people we're actually building on
experience of previous studies
and although it is true
that in situations such as the
the situation where we are at the moment
where the prevalence
of infection is is low we do know that
it is possible that some people
might test positive when they are not
carrying the infection but that is still
rare the tests are highly
highly accurate and we have undertaken
studies
previously where offering
these tests to contacts of cases
they have found to be very accurate and
the correlation of these tests with pcr
tests has been found to be very high
we will of course as part of the study
also be asking people
to take two pcr tests and everybody
who takes positive with a lateral flow
device as part of this study
will also be asked to take a
confirmatory pcr test
it does rely on
trusting people because they they have
to to self-test
um and you have to rely on people
actually carrying out the tests
properly themselves are you confident
that that would be that the case
routinely
well as you say trust is really
important and trust is
is key to our our public health response
uh
people will be required to submit uh
uh evidence of their daily tests every
day
uh they will be sent a reminder and of
course
if they do not submit their tests
they will be required they will be still
be required by law to isolate so if they
do not
take the daily test they will have to
isolate now as we know the vaccination
programme thus far has been hailed a
huge success
and we read in the papers this morning
that uh vaccinations are to begin in
secondary schools from september
what can you tell us about that well as
you say vaccination
is it has been a wonderful
success
it is fantastic to see the
evidence of the protection that the
vaccination program is providing
and i would recommend everybody to
to take up the offer of vaccination it
is really the best
weapon that we have against against this
deadly virus
but can you confirm that that will be
starting in secondary schools come
september
i'm not so i'm i'm not able to to
confirm that i'm i'm
you know i'm here to talk about this
this study particularly not not about
the details of the vaccination program
but as you know the government is
committed to
uh to rolling out the vaccination
program to the whole population as
quickly as possible
okay professor isabel oliver thank you
very much for sharing your expertise
with us this morning thank you thank you
thank you very much
okay let's take a look at the weather
for you now we're the naz
is it a little bit warmer today yeah
slightly warmer
um but basically the same as the last
few days so i'm
beginning to sound like a broken record
again we are looking at sunshine and
showers for uh this bank holiday sun
awards this
today sunday bank holiday monday's
looking wet and windy
i need to have a coffee
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so it's a showery picture
but a sunny one too
for this sunday bank holiday monday is
looking typically
unsettled with wet and windy conditions
so
for today it starts off fine much like
yesterday morning we
will see lots of sunshine out there
mainly dry conditions there are some
showers scattered about though mainly
across
northern eastern parts of the uk in the
northwest of england well some coastal
areas of
ireland and northern ireland too but
inland parts dry with sunshine
generally a bit of a frost maybe some
isolated fog patches too and a chilly
morning
going into this afternoon cloud bubbles
up showers do as well
so we are seeing sunshine at times but
also some showers that will be slow
moving
because the light winds they could be
quite prolonged in places they could be
actually quite heavy
with the risk of hail and thunder too
and maybe even some wintry outbreaks
across the
scottish mountains and perhaps for
northern parts of england over the high
ground
it is slightly warmer than it was
yesterday though uh temperatures
look to be reaching highs of around 11
to 12 degrees celsius possibly 13 to 15
locally across parts of the south and
then as we head into tonight the showers
will tend to fade away it will be a
mainly dry and clear night for central
and eastern areas where we're likely to
have a frost again it will be chilly
with some
mist and fog patches further west though
will be cloudier
less cold but wetter and windier with
rain
through tomorrow as well as strong winds
spreading eastwards across the uk island
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come we have all the sport with
jackie what have you got coming out
well it might not be the best day to be
a manchester united fan
i'm just saying if they lose today not
only will they have been beaten by the
old rivals liverpool but they'll also
hand the premier league title to
neighbours manchester city also on the
way heavyweights joseph parker and derek
chizzora
battle through a grueling 12-round
classic which splits the judge's
decisions and an agonizing
fall for britain's great thomas just
meters
from the wedding line
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready
so this was mr prosi's own personal mask
it wasn't sadly used in the film
um this was one that was given to him in
the early 1980s and he used it for kind
of fan conventions
bits of fun interviews etc so it's kind
of as close as you can get to having
darth vader's mask without it actually
being from the film
there's lots of really nice personal
items and some of the kind of the most
charming ones
uh those that were given to him from his
co-stars so we've got a lovely signed
picture of mark hamill
that says from your loving son similar
with carrie fisher
sir alec guinness peter cushing we've
got letters from peter cushing
it's kind of a really unique and very
charming collection of stuff
the salesman is is kind of around 80 to
100 000 pounds
uh we've broken nearly every record for
our own auction house in terms of the
number of bids
uh the speed of bids as i've been saying
all week
the sky is the limit
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
jack is here to tell us about the big
showdown the rivalry football starting
with that aren't you
yeah well you know will man city win the
title today they're going to win at some
point is it going to be today
possibly did the two boxes start
fighting about who would go into the
ring first
and mum sorted it out no yeah and why
did the right thomas fall off his bike
so many questions i've got a few of the
answers right now
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality committed to getting 100
million people 20
more active by 2025
well the best place it feels like to
start is the spurs game
and your performance and the result in
general how much did the club need that
to get the revenge from the previous
game that we had against them because we
still had the inside
everyone had the inside you know losing
like that at home
and um just for the point as well with
the result
that happened in the weekend it was good
for us
it was very important there was a really
nice moment after the game that the
cameras picked up you and ollie having a
little chat
it looked like he was complimenting you
on a part of your game what's your
relationship like with ollie at the
moment
well he wasn't complimenting me he was
he was telling me that i should have
scored
but but now obviously uh
we have a very good relation um
he understand me uh he put me on the
pitch
he trusts me to uh to play in the middle
on the left
and that's all the that's all the player
needs
there was a really interesting what we'd
call like a war of words between
oligonosula and jose mourinho
before the game and after the game and
it was amusing for us to watch what did
you guys make of it as players
i don't know what happened i'm sure
mourinho put something or said something
that would the people speak that's what
he does
and uh we got the result that we wanted
just uh ollie knows it and
we enjoyed that we enjoyed that moment
what do you think the differences are
between
jose mourinho's style of management and
only gonna social style of management
what i have now with the with the ollie
is different because he would
he wouldn't go against the players maybe
it doesn't put them
uh it's not like you put them on the
side and they don't
they don't exist anymore and i think
that's the difference between
mourinho and and oli
because once uh i had a great
relationship with the
with mourinho everybody see that and
the next day you don't know what
happened and that's the change the the
strange thing that uh
that i had with mourinho and i cannot
explain to you because even me i don't
know
tell us about the role that you play
because when you were bought by
manchester united it was a
a very boxer box midfielder kind of role
you've changed so much and at the
weekend we saw you play far right
in a front three what do you prefer i
like to do
obviously attacking i like to be in the
box i like to be this easy for my team
if i can do both i will do it i like to
defend as well
to recover bowling and get to the box i
just like to be free
and play my football for you to perform
at your best do you
feel that you need a consistent role or
are you happy to float around
and and do whatever it is that ollie
wants you to do i think for every player
you know you
always feel com you need to play when
you feel comfortable
when you're doing well there and you
carry on you keep doing it
um i think it will be harder it will be
more difficult for
someone to be consistent and play well
when
you change a lot the manager tell me to
be deeper i will be deeper i will give
my best there and if i have to be
a bit happier in the pocket i will be i
will do the same and
and be there try to be in front as well
help the team do much as i can
i'm in i'm in we're all in
to kick it out partnering to end racism
in sport
brian swanson and carver solokul on set
with me to discuss
if the super league is indeed dead and
if not what's going to happen
next and we'll have more on the
discussion about whether fans ownership
is a model for the future of english
football but next
we're going to hear from the england
captain harry kane who has praised fans
for protesting against the super league
supporters turned up outside the
tottenham hotspur stadium
before the game in the premier league
against southampton on wednesday to
voice
their objections to the proposals as
well as
chairman daniel levy and owners enoch
i'm surprised i'll be totally honest uh
come in that morning and obviously
found out probably 5-10 minutes before
it's announced so um
yeah surprise was obviously a lot of the
focus was on the
the carabao cup final and preparing for
that but um but
it's football i've been here now where
there's a couple managers been set and
i mean as a committed to getting 100
million people 20
more active by 2025.
[Music]
you're watching sky news breakfast
coming up
i'll be speaking to a conservationist
about the great migration
of nightingale songbirds
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to sky news breakfast
israel is holding a national day of
mourning after a deadly stampede killed
45 ultra-orthodox jews
at friday's lag bomber festival near
mount meron
the bodies of 32 of the worshippers have
been identified
but the process was suspended to allow
for sabbath the jewish day of rest
prime minister benjamin netanyahu has
promised an investigation into the cause
of the stampede
well let's cross now to tel aviv in
israel and speak to i-24
news middle east reporter alec pollard
alec
tell us exactly what will be happening
today
good morning julian so first of all in
the early hours of the morning the last
of the victims were identified at the
main forensic institute which means
there are funerals which are ongoing now
as we speak there is also a national day
of mourning as you mentioned all the
flags are flying at half
mast on official buildings throughout
the country many events have been
canceled all the sunday football matches
that were planned have been canceled so
much of the country coming to a
standstill to mourn
the dead and as this day progresses and
the week progresses
we will see people also progress from
the stage of mourning to the stage
of asking some very serious questions
and pointing the finger of blame
in various directions you mentioned the
national national inquiry which is
likely
coming but it should be mentioned that
there have been several state controller
reports over the years going back over a
decade 2008 2011
in which it was said very clearly that
this small pilgrimage site simply cannot
accommodate a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand people it was a
disaster
waiting to happen the writing was on the
wall written
clearly in very large letters and
everyone chose to look the other way
also because there are several different
authorities in charge of administering
that site it's a very complicated
situation but
certainly the writing was on the wall
and the question now is if people will
learn the lesson and if this
disaster will be averted
next time to make sure that it doesn't
happen again if the necessary
precautions
are put in place to make sure it doesn't
happen again
alex thank you very much for that
an important event in the calendar for
bird lovers now as thousands of
nightingale songbirds have made the
journey from africa to southern parts of
the uk
as the name suggests they like to sing a
number or two and one conservationist
has set up a series of events
to celebrate the birds let's take a
quick listen
to the nightingale song
[Applause]
joining me now from heinen woods in
gloucestershire is conservationist and
author of the nightingale notes on a
songbird
sam lee good morning to you uh thank you
very much for
for joining us um it's beautiful
listening to
that the sounds of the nightingale there
but i have to say i'm
quite ignorant i wouldn't know the
difference between a nightingale
and uh i don't know a lark what what is
specific
about the uh the sound from the
nightingale that you
particularly like well um
as the name suggests the nightingale is
a bird that likes to sing at night and
one of the few birds that sings
throughout the night for this
next six weeks uh and due to the end of
may uh
using their their incredible vocal range
a huge dynamic 1500 different sounds one
of the most virtuosic of all birds
and they sing through the night to try
and find their mate and it's an
exquisite experience in these spring
nights to
sit and listen and play music indeed and
gather people to experience this a real
one of nature's great phenomenons uh
tell us about the events that that
you're
running um to celebrate the nightingale
yeah so um the invitation is for
audiences to come and join me here in
these woods i'm actually in sussex
uh this time um for the next month
and uh people are treated to an amazing
experience of being in these very
precious woods
having dinner and food and store is all
about the mythology and folklore and
history of the nightingale and
cultures across northern hemisphere and
then with musicians we head
down into their habitat where we go into
this musical
collaboration and we play instruments
and i sing with the birds who sing
back incredibly they have this wonderful
correspondence
with human musicians how does that work
because
doesn't your human singing put them off
or distract them or silence them
do they actually sing with you this is
the incredible thing they're they're in
a very
uh amazing place of being firstly trying
to find a mate
you know they're calling out but they're
also very collaborative with each other
and thus what we find is that when
humans there in a very sensitive way
playing music as has been done across
the northern hemisphere for thousands of
years the playing of music
and the telling of tales with the birds
they are completely fearless and will
enter into this amazing
playful kind of collaboration
improvisation where they'll recognize
your music and
start to sing in key and you go into
this very very special
human bird sort of conversation
there's nothing like it on earth as an
experience guys
that is amazing i was totally unaware of
that so they'll actually join in
on the the key that that you're singing
in
yes indeed um we work with violinists
cellists clarinetists singers
uh mostly instrumentalists and and and
singers but from all different
musical traditions and the birds are
just so
amazingly accepting and and
dare i say kind of uh like allowing of
this
you know we're not there we're not
affecting their breeding at all it's
it's having actually our presence here
has had great impact on the population
so
it's a very sensitive and very
thoughtful and romantic affair
there i say sounds wonderful so
interesting
samli thank you so much for speaking to
us and happy international dawn
chorus day as well which it is today
thank you
let's catch up on the weather now see if
it's great weather for nightingales who
knows
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning well it's another day of
sunny spells and showers
and it is going to be a rather wet and
windy bank holiday monday as well so
typical bank holiday weekend conditions
starting off
fine this morning like it was yesterday
morning and the day before that it is
chilly though and there are frosty
conditions out there and there are some
showers scattered about mainly across
coastal areas of ireland northern
ireland the north west of england wales
and
the uh east of the uk as well but
generally it's fine but then as we head
into this afternoon cloud amounts will
bubble up there will still be some
bright or sunny spells
but where it gets quite cloudy there
will be some showers about and some of
them are likely to be quite slow moving
because the winds are light
and so they might be quite prolonged if
you get caught out in one and they could
be quite heavy and thundery with a risk
of hail
maybe even some wintriness across the
tops of the scottish mountains
it's actually feeling slightly warmer
compared to yesterday this time of the
year the sun is very strong so
we are looking at temperatures widely of
around highs of 11 to 12 degrees celsius
possibly 13 to 15 down towards
southern areas so not too bad into
tonight the showers will fade away then
tomorrow
wet and windy from the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
at 7 43 you're watching sky news
breakfast after the break we'll take you
through the stories making this
morning's newspapers
with julie bindle and esther do stay
with us
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh who were digging up
the soil of their dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone they they can't arrest
everybody
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
are you saying that
doesn't say hitler
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
safety ridge podcast for the ones who
want to know more welcome to the all-out
politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news story
cast
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know allergies affect
almost 50 percent of the uk population
particularly pollen and dust the pollen
reports sponsored by philips connected
air purifiers
much like the last couple of days today
will be another day of sunny spells and
showers
after a mainly dry and fine start some
of the showers will be heavy and
thundery
with the risk of hail but it'll feel
slightly warmer than recently
so although it'll be a showery day it'll
still feel mild in any sunshine
therefore pollen levels will be moderate
for most places again
tree pollen is airborne at the moment a
mixture of birch
oak and ash but also plain pollen in
some cities and spores will increase
temporarily
after any rain the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
with us now to take us through the
newspapers journalists and feminist
campaigner julie bindle and the writer
and political commentator
esther kraku welcome back to you both
let's start
with the telegraph front page sunday
telegraph esther
and this story about home testing
possibly replacing
the uh 10-day self-isolation these are
the trials
that are soon to be starting
yeah so it's part of the um plan to
us out of you know the lockdown mode
that we've been in for the last year
instead of you know 10 days of isolation
um
if you if you do um if you leave the
country
or if you are at risk of coming into
contact with covered you can have the
at-home test kids that's
something that they're testing at the
moment so just to get people out and
about moving
so we're not isolated for a week and a
half
um if we have an ex risk of being
exposed to the virus i think it's one of
the key measures that we should be
taking instead of
you know telling people to basically
have these mini lock down of their lives
um
for 10 days to stop the risk of
transferring the virus onto other people
which is which is great you know it's
one of the
one of the things that i feel is most
optimistic as well all these trials that
are being uh
taking place especially um even the one
that they had in liverpool with a bunch
of youngsters meeting up i think about
six thousand young kids
that met up in a kind of a nightclub
setting to try and see about the
transmission rate of
covert of people in would be like a
normal night out for most young people
so these are the kind of
measures that are being taken to you
know make the country feel a bit more
confident as we come out of this
lockdown hopefully by june
um which is what is planned at the
moment yes you refer to the uh 3000
people that attended the
the rave in liverpool that had to test
before
and afterwards we wait to see the
results of that whether that has been a
success let's move on
to the mail uh online uh julie and this
is uh matt hancock
reopening the debate on legalizing
assisted suicide
yes there was a survey of uh gps across
britain last year and 50
were in support they say of
assisting people to die who have
terminal illness and in fact
matt hancock himself who was always
against assisted suicide
changed his mind after um talking with
sir paul cosford who was the public
health director who died after
um living with cancer for four years and
of course this this debate has been
raging across the world actually many
countries for a number of years
similar laws have been passed in
countries such as switzerland and
belgium
holland parts of the us and australia
and we know that there is the dignitas
clinic in switzerland
where people can actually go not and
this is something that they can ask
their friends
and family to assist them with dying at
dignitas whereas what we're looking at
at the moment what
matt hancock wants to look at is
doctor-assisted dying
but actually it dignitas and this is one
of the things that concerns me
a large percentage i think it's 40 if
not more
of people that choose to die at dignitas
don't have
a terminal illness which means that this
could be other issues
depression uh mental illness etc
and i'm concerned that this is a bit of
a quick fix issue
and that if we actually pass this law
two things concern me one
is um coercion and abuse
from carer to the person with the
illness
they could well be pressurized into
taking their lives there have been some
criminal
charges against carers who have pushed
people into
into taking their lives but also that
this might lead to a situation where
it's far more normalized for people to
be left struggling with terrible
illnesses such as depression
and that this is a way out as opposed to
strengthening
our mental health program but at the
moment as i say
it's just a consideration and this is
something
that will run and run as as an issue at
the moment people can get
14 years in prison in prison for
assisting someone to die
and of course that would apply to a
doctor um that that did this outside of
the regulation
yeah and just worth saying that anyone
sort of seeking uh
help can contact samaritan's free on 116
1
2 three uh let's move on to
the mail and the the picture there of a
sweat
soaked doctor in india this article
looking at the
covered situation
in india and through the perspective of
the the health workers the doctors and
their their workload and what they're
having to deal with
yeah i mean obviously over the last
couple of weeks we've noticed a
huge surge in covered cases in india in
particular the
sort of indian variant of the of the
virus
and it's just been really shocking to
the world system i mean this is just a
clear example of
you know a doctor that's been in ppe for
hours at a time trying to
save these patients they've been you
know pictures of people being
dumped on the side of the road it's just
it's just awful like an apocalyptic
situation
and it kind of highlights a lot of the
failings of you know the
the local indian health system but it's
also just shows how
badly this virus can get out of control
if it's not managed um
properly and uh it is it is a really
tragic situation what's going on in
india right now there obviously calls
for charities to
um send over help and any sort of
assistance that you know we can but it's
a really
awful situation yes and the country
asking
excuse me for for international help uk
to
to help it build its own nightingale
hospitals a
facility that actually in the end we
didn't use here did we
yeah we did i mean it wasn't sort of i
mean the situation in the uk was
inspired but i think the pictures that
we've been seeing and the kind of
footage that's come out of the media is
a
bit more graphic um in the obviously
levels of development are different so
how things are handled there is clearly
there is a staff difference
um but yes it is it is quite a terrible
situation at the moment
julie to the the telegraph and this the
follow-up on the story the the tragedy
in israel with
45 people losing their lives at the
festival the lag bomber festival
uh the prime minister uh launching an
investigation
and a day of mourning now but but
criticisms that warnings perhaps about
the numbers of people that were likely
to be in attendance those warnings being
ignored
yes in 2016 a police report
warned of overcrowding there were a
hundred thousand
ultra-orthodox jews at this pilgrimage
the venue was far too
small for this and in fact i think this
is
this is similar to hillsborough where
[Music]
what some reports are saying is that on
the actual night of the disaster
the police had set up a barrier which
then prevented
a number of people leaving in fact two
members of my family were there and they
were close to the front but before
the disaster happened and they got to
the back
um of the venue and managed to escape
but it took them three hours to get out
and they were saying you know the police
have a lot to answer for but
until we see the results of the
investigation
it's really difficult to know who is to
blame of course
it looks like this might be the fault of
a number of different
um bodies but certainly the barrier that
was set up by police
uh on the night looks as if as i say it
could be analogous with the with the
hills pretty disaster but
it's terrible i mean the pm is saying
that this is
this is the country's worst disaster to
date
and of course we'll be hearing much more
about this as time goes on people have
traveled
from canada from the us from europe from
all over yes
and i'm sure that and as we say the
investigation
is being launched uh thank you both for
taking us through the papers this
morning julie and esther good to see you
thank you so much